uh nicole bazemore justin collins and
arabella murray uh all wanted um
our take but they're gonna get my take
on uh a recent study that was published
um
and an npr article about it so the study
in the npr article will both
be linked in the show notes the title of
this for the record by the way uh i've
already weighed in on this topic but i
keep all of my perspectives behind a
paywall so you got to subscribe to mass
if you want
my take on artificial sweeteners all
right
uh anyway so the title of the study in
question uh published i think last month
or in october
was obesity and sex-related associations
with differential effects of sucralose
versus sucrose on appetite and reward
processing colon a randomized control
trial and i gotta say
most of the time when a when a study
gets a lot of headlines and a lot of
press it tends to have a very
uh simple and audacious title so kudos
to these researchers for getting an npr
spot for this paper because that's a
convoluted title um
but anyway so uh what this study did
is there were three conditions um so
subjects consumed water a sucralose
sweetened beverage sucralose is the
generic associated with the brand named
splenda
and a sucrose sweetened beverage so
sucrose is table sugar
and it was a crossover study so all of
the subjects completed the same testing
after consuming water after consuming a
sucralose sweetened beverage and after
consuming a sucrose sweetened beverage
with a washout period between each one
and uh i'll note most of the outcomes in
this study were related to brain imaging
and i'm not going to even touch on those
because that's not
even even within spitting distance of my
area of expertise um
yeah i don't know the first thing about
fmri i understand in general what it's
measuring but uh you know i'm i'm not a
i'm not a neurology expert i can't claim
to uh
be able to interpret those outcomes with
any meaningful expertise so i'm just
going to let them be
i
uh did one very mri heavy study
as a grad student but would you even
believe that i was not the mri expert on
the team interesting yeah so
unfortunately i also cannot comment yes
but
what i am good at
is arithmetic and uh knowing dude you're
you're as good when numbers are bigger
or smaller i was going to say you're as
good at addition and subtraction as
virtually any of my peers
i'll take it
um
so yeah they uh they they basically gave
people these three beverages and and
look to see
like how they impact different reward
centers of the brain and whatnot uh but
also on a much more practical level um
two hours after they consumed these
beverages uh they consumed an ad libitum
meal with kind of a buffet style
eating uh setup so you know people could
get a bunch of different foods and just
eat as much of them as they felt like
they wanted to eat
um and they were looking at the impact
following water sucralose or sucrose
ingestion on food intake
and so they did find
that on average
comparing the sucrose and sucralose
conditions
that subjects at the ad libido meal did
consume more calories following the
sucralose condition than the sucrose
condition
so that
is consistent potentially with the idea
that artificial sweeteners might
increase food cravings or like the the
sweetness doesn't come with calories and
so
it's not as satisfying as it could be
and then that might make people want to
eat more at a subsequent meal
and they also found that there was a sex
effect so when they stratified it by sex
they found
that relative to the sucrose condition
the male subjects didn't eat more
following the sucralose beverage but the
female subjects did they ate about 100
calories on average more
following a sucralose sweetened beverage
than a sucrose sweetened beverage so
that's again seems consistent with the
idea that ah maybe uh maybe artificial
sweeteners are no good maybe it
increases appetite or food cravings or
whatever but as i mentioned the devil is
in the details here and the piece of
information that i haven't shared with
you yet
is the sucrose sweetened beverage
contained about 300 calories
and so
in total combining the calories consumed
in the beverage and the calories
consumed in the subsequent meal
the male subjects consumed about 300
fewer calories uh in the sucralose
condition than the sucrose condition and
the female subjects consumed about 200
total fewer calories again counting both
the meal and the beverage
so with that context
in total the sucralose condition did
actually result in a relatively lower
total energy intake um compared to the
sugar compared to the sugar
um and so like
i don't know to me i i care about that
maybe more than uh
brain imaging research
like you know if if people are given the
opportunity to eat everything they want
to eat and they're still consuming
overall fewer calories following
artificial artificially sweetened
beverages than sugar sweetened beverages
that still seems to suggest to me that
at minimum the artificial sweeteners are
fine when it comes to uh
promoting overall energy intake
and
sounds like you're going to say
something well i was just going to say
you could argue that this is
evidence of kind of the ideal use case
for a artificially sweetened beverage
where it's like oh for the totality of
this meal if you swap this beverage it
will still taste nice but your total
calories will be lower yeah so that's
pretty good i agree
uh and to be clear the beverage wasn't
consumed with the meal it was consumed
but two hours prior but yeah i i agree
conceptually uh so anyway i
don't find the results of this study to
be particularly scary or to suggest that
the artificial sweeteners you know
enhance appetite or cravings to a degree
that would likely be deleterious
and i'll note that that is also in
keeping with a
meta-analysis that was published last
year by laviata molina and colleagues
title was effects of non-nutritive
sweeteners on body weight and bmi in
diverse clinical contexts systematic
review and meta-analysis that will also
be linked in the show notes
uh but it's straightforward they just
looked for all of the rcts that ran for
at least four weeks that compared a
non-nutritive sweetener which
i tend to just call artificial
sweeteners
not all of them are artificial sugar
alcohols aren't artificial but whatever
it's what people would often refer to as
artificial sweeteners uh
so it compared uh studies lasting at
least four weeks
comparing non-nutritive sweeteners
versus
either sugar sweetened beverages or
water
as a uh control condition
and it found that uh kind of in all of
the studies pooled together
non-nutritive sweeteners
led to uh negative effects on body
weight and i mean that negative in a
numeric sense so
either less weight gain or greater
weight loss then when they broke it down
further
just for example just looking at the
studies comparing it against sucrose
versus studies comparing non-nutritive
sweeteners against water they found that
the effect of water and non-nutritive
sweeteners or not beverages sweetened
with non-nutritive sweeteners they had
similar effects on body weight so
water did not have superior effects
in other words but neither did
non-nutrient sweeteners and then
compared against
sucrose non-nutritive sweeteners did
lead to a numerically negative impact on
on body weight and bmi
um and then they also looked at the type
of dietary intervention so
in uh restricted intervention so like
when people were put on a diet that was
intentionally reduced calorie for the
purpose of losing weight um
it didn't really seem to matter what
sort of beverages they consumed like
non-nutritive sweeteners did not
enhance weight loss in those studies but
they also didn't have a negative impact
on weight loss in those studies
but then in studies with uncontrolled
diets they did have a significant uh
numerically negative impact on body
weight and bmi so
you know um
again i i care less about brain imaging
than a meta-analysis that's actually
looking at changes in body weight and
bmi over time and in that context uh
non-nutritive sweeteners seem to be
neutral to positive if you're
interpreting
either greater weight loss or
uh less weight gain as as a positive
effect
the one thing that i will note uh just
as as a caveat and i wouldn't say
potential calls for concern but just
kind of a thing to look out for
potentially
is you know there are a bunch of
non-nutrient sweeteners or artificial
sweeteners out there
so the the study i started uh talking
about initially for this segment um
looked at sucralose again brand name
there is splenda uh but most of the
research in this area looks at aspartame
and then there are also various sugar
alcohols
a couple of studies look at uh saccharin
and honestly i don't even call saccharin
an artificial sweetener it's not sweet
like i don't care what people say
saccharine's not sweet it just tastes
like [ __ ] uh same thing with stevia
stevie is not an artificial sweetener
it's an artificial bitterer uh like i
i've seen
here
okay here here's the thing they call
that one a non-artificial bitterer yeah
whatever i don't care so this is um
the thing that i think i get the most
heated about when it comes to like
diet culture and people trying to make
like healthy desserts and whatnot
like
because there there's the
the high protein dessert
community and the people with
undiagnosed orthorexia community is a
circle
i believe and so there's a lot of kind
of like health halo stuff around like oh
natural is good stevia it's natural it's
not it's not like aspartame it's not
like sucralose so like yeah make these
little [ __ ] protein balls and use
three cups of stevia and like it's gonna
be sweet and it's going to be great and
then like you know people will be like
oh man like it's not quite as good as
the real thing but i still like it
you're lying to yourselves no one likes
stevia stevia tastes terrible uh
if you want
i don't generally do plugs if i'm not
getting paid i'm not sponsored by
splenda but honestly the next time you
make one of those [ __ ] recipes sub
out the stevia for splenda or just like
a store brand of sucralose i promise you
it's going to taste so much better
stevia is terrible and uh
if you if you don't agree with me you're
lying to yourself and i will not hear
arguments to the contrary
anyway
getting back on topic uh yeah there are
a lot of
sweeteners that kind of fall under the
umbrella of non-nutritive sweeteners and
what i'll note is the meta-analysis i
just talked about looking at weight in
bmi
um
i don't i don't have the numbers
directly in front of me but if memory
serves like 80 of the studies were
aspartame studies like aspartame is
far and away the most
well-studied non-nutritive sweetener and
i believe that only one of the studies
in that meta-analysis did look at
sucralose so
it would be fallacious to necessarily
assume that the impact of all
non-nutritive sweeteners on hunger or
appetite or weight or bmi are all
identical um i'm not arguing that so it
is possible
that the impact of sucralose on weight
and bmi over time
might differ from the effects of
aspartame um
but
you know so so that is a door that's
still open
but the uh the the study that the npr
article was about that that uh i was
asked about on facebook
it's not sufficient
for me to become scared of sucralose or
to think that it it would have a
negative impact on uh on weight over
time
yeah and by the way the same is true a
lot of times people ask about how
non-nutritive sweeteners impact the gut
microbiome that's another area of
research where there are many studies on
it
not a ton but there are several but
again it's very aspartame dominated uh
you know we definitely need more
research looking at
some of the other popular non-nutritive
sweeteners but this study um and this is
not um to be critical of the original
researchers because they had a very
practical component to their study
um but one of the things that that i get
a kick out of is when you have
conversations usually on the internet um
and someone will be using mechanistic
data
to make conclusions about an applied
outcome
when we absolutely definitely do have
applied research on the topic you know
like
i saw a thread the other day where
someone was like oh dude carbs are so
bad and i was like how do you know that
and they're like
look at this study from five decades ago
when they infused insulin i'm like dude
these people didn't even eat a carb like
what do you what are you going on about
but yeah it's the same kind of thing
where like sometimes i'll look at these
extrapolations of
mechanisms that often tend to lean in
the scary direction and i'm like
dude you know we know what happens when
when people eat that right like
yeah it's uh and that's not to say that
mechanistic uh data is not informative
or helpful or important but like
if we have actually seen what humans do
in a very specific context and that's
what your question is about
it's okay to also use some of that data
too one of uh
an instance of that that i
previously found very funny and i don't
say i don't say previously because i no
longer find it funny but i say
previously because i don't see people
making this exact claim anymore but
whatever i'm gonna put some people on
blast in the past uh
so
it used to be maybe like five or six
years ago people would use um
acute muscle protein synthesis research
to make
very firm arguments about training
frequency and i i personally did this a
little bit as well um
not to
an extreme degree but i'm i'm slightly
putting uh a past version of myself
on blast so consider this uh a slight
contextual clarification uh for me as
well
but anyway um
so yeah you look at uh you look at
research looking at protein synthesis
following resistance training
in trained lifters and often times you
you will only see elevations in muscle
protein synthesis
after a resistance training about
lasting
12 hours or 24 hours
and from that i didn't make claims quite
this extreme but i i did see this exact
claim like look
as far as training frequency goes if
you're only hitting a muscle once per
week you're building muscle one day per
week and you're losing muscle six days
per week
you will
at best tread water but there's really
no way
to build muscle with a training
frequency of just once per week it has
to be at least two or three times per
week but
honestly every day is probably best
because because these elevations are
like maybe 24 hours tops
and it's like brother there's there's a
lot of research here like
oh
a lot i would say a
at the time probably a majority of the
longitudinal resistance training studies
used a per muscle training frequency of
once per week these days i think the
average is is closer to twice per week
in the research but
back then man most of the research on
resistance training you were looking at
per muscle frequencies of once per week
and it's like
they're growing man they're getting
they're getting bigger uh
so yeah it's like extrapolating acute
results to
uh long-term assumptions that
are fully contradicted by an enormous
amount of research
uh
even at the time when i was very much on
the high frequency train i was like
some of y'all need to cool your jets
like you you can't you can't go that far
with it yeah